uh so yesterday I had to take my shirt
off so Brad did that I don't know how I
haven't seen the footage yet I'm wearing
the shirt they shut up I'm so tired of
all this ever since I got to LA I've
been so busy it's just been doing so
much everyone wants to meet and it's
really nice and everyone wants to do
stuff but I haven't had any time for
myself and it's just do you ever feel
like when that happens to you just going
crazy I don't know what do you think I
will in my honest opinion I'm afraid
you're being a little [ __ ] yeah yeah
can I agree
so I'm going to the gym now thank
[ __ ] god finally if you ever what if
you work out and you don't get to do it
I go [ __ ] crazy I just want to
[ __ ] punch someone oh my god I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry
I think that was the most amount of time
someone has ever said bro to me but it
was cool parking in this place is
two-and-a-half dollar per 50 minutes
that's [ __ ] crazy I'm out of here
wait alright so I calculated that's two
hundred and fifty dollars okay I'm dying
two hundred fifty dollars for a day la
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you okay I'm
gonna stop like double is triggered
[Music]
ah feel a lot better I feel so much
better having gone to the gym now I keep
driving on the wrong side of the road
just now I was like why is that woman
driving straight towards me what the
[ __ ] is your problem
oh wait I'm it's a miracle we haven't
crashed yet let's just say that so now
we're gonna go out find out another
present for Michael that's spoiled son
of a [ __ ] keep reading all the comments
on the first video I'm really taking
them to heart because I I spend like a
week trying to prepare for these vlogs
which I know isn't like a huge amount of
time but considering we do daily videos
I wanted to work out
and it seems like you guys are liking it
it's also fun for me to feel really
invested in something doing something
different and I appreciate all the
feedback know the constructive criticism
that helps me grow that I just Heil I
think I just it's a good thing this
camera zooms in way too much
are you getting it we're in Santa Monica
Wow wait didn't we buy I did for Michael
already yeah but we have to get another
gift for Micah cause he'll be like oh
you just got me a printer everyone loves
Michael in the vlogs and it bothers me
so much why don't you love me tell me
this is my blog people are gonna see me
not girls oh my god where's your shirt
you ripped it up so I made it all kind
of like really cold yeah
so it kind of almost works it's still
bad but it almost looks like it was kind
of meant to be so bad it's the only way
to do it it's the only way it's pretty
clever yeah Jamie I think it's gonna
come to a point where we start doing
really bad [ __ ] to them yeah
[Music]
we always wears the same way now you
won't look like [ __ ]
Michael is I was like I want to take
physical pictures but you don't have any
friends Michael so we get in this and we
put it in the frame it's perfect we took
a picture off yeah we put it in the
frame put in the frame and we rent it
you need the front well again this let's
get in this
[Music]
we're heading back about gifts for
Michael and he better like him that's
all I'm gonna say really tired it's a
tough life to live
spending money excuse me excuse me can I
get any more can you give me all right
excuse me can you give me a ride okay
okay I open one second ten yard when I
was 14 there was his DJ called DJ Adolph
which would just sample all this Hitler
mixes and it was the best [ __ ] and I
would play it at my house and then a
neighbor heard it and they come over and
the 11 oh we're stuck in traffic
hey Goblin could you play some music ah
yeah
thank you
[Music]
here is the actual behind by the US snap
out what happened to you was weird you
stayed like swerving all over the place
wait what happened it's been like what
am i it's been six weeks you were in a
coma for six weeks
I remember the coma I remember every day
they would feed me through a tube
[Music]
that that looks so good a special
message special message for my
[Music]
here
don't be sad
we're cut we're coming back free just
kidding face thanks recording run away
[Music]
look at my car everybody's saying you're
so cute ah birthday no I mean only on
your birthday it's your birthday it's
rubber flying Michael happy birthday I'm
not a speech person oh yes I am
Michael you're the worst person thank
you ever made a lot of times I just
dread the fact that you are part of my
life and how we ended up like this but
you're also very kind person oh you're
very sweet I'm the weekend apparently
very cute a lot of people think Michael
is very cute I'm really glad you're here
celery ring celebrating the birthday and
let's just drink this damn socket happy
birthday Michael
let's open again
[Music]
for my wife that's how we see you
Michael
the wife we never wanted Michael you
always say I want to have you are I want
to have memories that are physical
because in this modern day and age I
want a camera so there you go ed to try
on
you also have friends now that we take a
picture where's friend oh thank you very
much I wanted to borrow I wanted to buy
I know as you were talking about yeah
now kiss kissing it's my book yeah good
you ain't even go close any fate ha
that's my wish now that's his birthday
we're targeting with you give him a kiss
on the cheek it's bath time for all the
harassment
all right day three of our nabo did
anyone get a strike did anyone get a
strike you know I
okay maybe I got one whatever um I live
like you enjoy it I appreciate that you
guys are showing so much support for the
Burton bow
see you in the next episode
Alberta Bob
[Music]